is Guardians 3 your final Marvel film
yeah I mean at least for the time being
I mean never say never who knows but for
the time being yeah What Becomes of the
guardian's characters well I think you
have to see volume three to find it
actually scared
you know I mean it's like we'll you know
we'll see where they where they go but
this is definitely the end of their
story is is this this specific group of
Guardians yeah we're looking for the
legendary Kevin Bacon
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present what's up hello Ash how are you
I'm so good how are you I'm pretty good
I love the special oh my God it's so
good it's a gift oh thanks yeah well you
know it's I'm a real Christmasy guy so I
love it and I love doing a Christmas
special I always wanted to do something
like that and to me this is just the
gift of the Marvel fans a Great Hero
named Kevin Bacon
entire city full of people with sticks
up their butts that dancing wow
it's the greatest thing there is Kevin
Bacon is mentioned in the first Guardian
so how do you call him up and be like
I'm gonna kidnap you for Christmas you
know I've known Kevin for a while Kevin
was the villain in my movie Super with
Rayne Wilson and uh and Elliot page
we've kept in touch and I said and and
there's a great story which maybe if you
talk to Kevin he should tell you but
about how he went to see Guardians 1 in
a theater and I sat there and all of a
sudden they're talking about me my jaw
just dropped I I just was like I'm
looking around to the people in the
theater are you hearing what I'm hearing
you know that's me so I I just called
him up and I said listen we're doing a
Christmas special we're doing a holiday
special and the story is Tom and mantis
want to give Peter Quill something
special for Christmas so they decide to
give him you and I want you to come in
and play yourself he would just
immediately said yes and uh you know of
course we let him read the pages which
were fun and then that was it we were
off and running do you think you can
toss me over the gate if you
[Music]
what are you doing I love the
relationship between mantis and Drax and
I also love the character of of mantis
and I love how talented both palm
clementia and Dave Batista are and I
really wanted to put them at the center
of this story I think they've become
background characters for the last few
movies that they've been in they have
not had an opportunity to do very much
so to be able to put them at the center
of this was a lot of fun for me and I
also think it was kind of necessary
because you know I'm actually working in
a lot of Mythology that's going to be
important in volume three through the
Christmas special and one of those
things is you can see the difference
between mantis when we saw her in volume
2 which is the only time we've really
focused on her character when she was
sort of beaten down by this guy that had
enslaved her and how much more
comfortable she is with herself today in
terms of her relationship to Dave her
relationship to the Guardians as a whole
and she's just a much more a louder
character shall we say that's the thing
is I you know I was going into it being
like it's gonna be this like little
contained story but there are a lot of
seeds that I feel like are leading
directly into Guardians 3. yeah some of
that was just my ability to sneak in
things that I don't have to mention
volume three because when you have a
movie it's just like you have so many
things you got to bring up when you're
you know hopping between these different
franchises and so the fact that we had
Cosmo the dog the fact that they have
this amazing spaceship called the Bowie
that's four stories tall for in real
life that thing was four stories tall
and that they have um you know they've
bought nowhere from The Collector that's
their home base now all of those things
are important to volume three you know
the weird thing about it though is that
volume 3 is so much more emo I mean it's
very emotional and it's got the fun that
we expect from the guardians but it's
also an incredibly serious story in some
ways where we tell the end of the story
of the Guardians and the end of the
story of rocket and how where he came
from we need to go back to the beginning
to tell the ending and so shooting that
for a few days and then going and
shooting this whacked out Christmas
special and then back to shooting the
movie and then back to the crazy special
these I thought of these as almost like
snow days shooting this show because the
stakes were so much lower in so many
ways that's what I was going to ask you
because when we were on stage at Paul H
close to buy Yours Truly everyone was
crying and I was like this is gonna be a
really emotional movie yeah well I think
at the heart of it it's always been
emotional you know I think that at the
heart of it you know when you think of
it the guardian's journey started with a
boy watching his mother die in front of
him and going away and you know running
off to another place and in a way that's
the you know that's a guy who's running
away from the trauma of his childhood
going off into another land you know I
think that many of us have different
ways we've escaped our childhood dramas
and gone to someplace else and that's at
the core of the Guardian story so
although there's always been this fun
and this funny stuff there is this very
sort of dark undercurrent underneath you
know and a lot of it has to do with
rocket for me I'm not ready I'm not
prepared so we also get like the latest
edition of Groot so we had baby group
angsty teen group what is the approx age
of this screw and what do we call him
he's swole Groot
he is like jacked he's jacked man he's
jacked I think he's like he's a
Collegiate like excitable football Groot
I think you can see now that he's very
much a different group than the original
Groot he's grown into somebody quite
different and he's becoming his own uh
not person his own group I I didn't name
him slow group that was somebody on
Twitter but I thought it was really
funny so I've been calling him small
group ever since I think yeah I think we
run with that I have to leave you and I
don't want to but I know well I miss you
Ashley I'll see you soon I'll definitely
see you around Guardians three times so
we'll see that's not that far away
absolutely I'm so proud of you thank you
[Music]